Logic himself.
>> How you doing, man?
[laughter]
>> What's going on, brother? [music]
[music and singing]
time and I I probably got like 15 15
minutes 20 minutes so I got to get to
the airport but
>> No problem.
>> Yeah. So I obviously believe Jesus is
God. There's a bunch of verses in the
Bible that teach that Jesus is God. You
obviously think Jesus is not God. So
what are your thoughts man? What's
what's your argument from the Bible that
Jesus is not God?
>> Yeah I got you. My bad. So simply we
would see that uh Jesus if he is God.
Okay. Let me let me ask you a question.
Is there any necessary attribute that
God can lack and still be God?
>> Any necessary? You mean any essential
attribute of God? No.
>> Essential as Yes. So, go ahead.
>> Yes. Jesus. Jesus has all the Jesus has
properties to be God. [laughter]
>> Oh, Jesus. Jesus has all the essential
properties.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The Bible describes creator,
all powerful, all knowing, omnipresent,
all of it.
>> I bet you you know where I'm about to go
right now.
>> Where? What? The hour. What? Gaining
wisdom. What? What? Where are you?
>> Oh, Aiden. Yeah. You want to talk about
Aiden? Let's talk about Aiden
>> if you want to.
>> Yeah, no problem. So, I have a question.
Do you know better than the translators?
Uh, I wouldn't say that.
>> Okay. So, why did the translators
translate it as no?
>> Well, the word oiden has a large range.
So, it's it's going to be translated as
no, but the meaning will carry dependent
on the context. Similar to how like if
you go to, for example, if you go to
Genesis 5, it talks about how Adam knew
his wife and she bore him a son. Right?
Now, why do they translate it as no? Why
didn't they just say sexual intercourse?
>> So, so let's look at that verse. You
want to look at that verse, please?
>> Sure. If you go to Genesis, I believe
it's Genesis 5.
>> But, but hold on. Why? Why are we
conflating languages now?
>> We're not conflating languages. You said
about the translators, right? So, why
>> talking about Yeah, I specifically
mentioned I specifically mentioned the
word the Greek word.
>> Yeah, but you then asked me You then
asked me, "Do I know better than the
translators? Why would the translators
translate if it means if it means if it
means to declare, why would they
translate it as no?" So, I'm giving you
an example of where they translate the a
word as no, but it doesn't mean like
cognitive knowledge. It means sexual
intercourse. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. I I I I Okay, I get you. But what
I'm telling you is we're talking about
the We're not talking about Hebrew.
We're talking about the Greek here.
Understand?
>> No. Well, I mean, you you asked me the
basis of a of issue. So, do you do you
have a problem with a translator
translating a word as no, but it means
something different? Like it doesn't
mean cognitive knowledge.
>> No, no, no problem. I can grant you the
Hebrew. I'll grant you this Hebrew word.
Okay.
>> But we're talking about the Greek right
now.
>> Yeah. It's the same thing with Oiden.
with oiden the word translates as no but
the meaning carries is to make to make
known or to declare.
>> No problem. Can you can you can you
substantiate that? Go ahead.
>> Yeah, it's in the it's in the
concordance in the lexicon.
>> So, so for example go to what is do do
you do you have an example for one
second? Okay, no problem. One sec. No
problem. One second. Um what is what is
the root word of oden?
>> Uh I don't know but I can give you an
example of what I'm talking about.
>> Okay. So, so the root word so the root
word of oiden right in the if you've
read the concordance it would tell you
that the word the root word of is which
is to know as it's used in the next
verse o however you want to pronounce it
no problem as it says in the next verse
in 33 let me pull it up for you so you
know I don't I don't want you doing a
lot of work you know it says appreciate
you [laughter]
>> no problem it says
oat right there you go beautiful it's
the perfect indic a indicative active
second person plural and that is the
verb. But if we see in the 32 as well,
it says it's also the per it's a verb
perfect indic indicative active, right?
There's no person there's what is the
what is the difference between oiden and
oida in this?
>> It's just the form of the word how it's
used in the sentence. It would be the
difference like ran or run.
>> Yes, no problem. So can you show me
where in the Bible or sorry not in the
Bible in in in the New Testament,
Matthew, Mark, wherever you want to go.
Can you tell me can you can you go ahead
and show me how it's used to declare?
>> Yeah. So, go to 1 Corinthians chapter 2.
>> Let's see this.
>> Chapter 2:2. In 1 Corinthians chapter
2:2, do you see where where Paul says,
"I decided to know nothing."
>> Yeah. So, where's Okay,
>> that word right there.
>> I decided anything to know. Edenai.
>> Yes.
>> Edenai. Let's look at Eden. No problem.
So, Eden,
>> you don't want to click on the go back
to it. You want to click on the number.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. You're right. You're
right. You're right. You're right. So,
let's
>> same same word. Same word.
>> Yep.
>> No problem. No problem. Oh, there. There
you go. There you go. Right. Let's look.
Let's look at the helps word studies.
Huh. So,
>> wait. Just really quick before you look
at that
>> properly. One sec. One second. One
second. To properly to see with physical
eyes as it naturally bridges us to the
metaphorical sense perceiving mentally
seeing. This is akin to the expressions
I see what you mean. I see what you are.
>> Mhm.
>> Saying or eo seeing what what become
seeing that becomes knowing. Then that
is a getaway. And then it then is a
getaway to grasp the spiritual truth
from the physical plane. Eido then is
physically seeing which should be the
con the the constant bridge dimensional
spiritual seeing which is in in what do
you call it? We can make this very thing
as as comprehension, right? So So one
second, let me ask you what is what is
comprehension?
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> Yeah. What what is comprehension?
>> Hold on. Can I comprehend?
What is comprehension? Can you answer my
question?
>> Let's slow down. Notice I've
>> going to slow down. Can you answer my
question?
>> Notice I've answered all of your
questions up to now. So let me at least
let me at least expound on what? No
problem. Can you answer my question?
What is
>> Just one second. What is comprehension?
Notice how you're interrupting me every
time I speak. For some reason, I know
what's going on.
>> Go ahead.
>> So go ahead. Thank you. I appreciate it.
So 1 Corinthians chapter 2:2, you asked
me, you asked me to show you a u a
passage in the New Testament where the
word oiden is used to declare, right? To
make known something. So I gave you 1
Corinthians chapter 2:2 where Paul says,
"When I came to you, I decided to know
nothing except Jesus Christ and him
crucified." So here we have a clear
example where the word oiden is used and
it's translated as no, where it's used
to make something known or to declare
something. You you understand what I'm
saying?
>> No problem. No problem. Right. So let's
we looked at the helps word studies,
right? And we see that eido in oida is
to probably to see with properly to see
with physical eyes as it naturally
bridges into the metaphorical sense
mentally seeing.
>> I have to get going cuz I have to pick
up my friends from the airport like I
told you. But
>> yeah, I got you
point. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So so see so when I tell you like
yo I see what you mean. What does that
mean? Like I understand what you're
saying, right?
>> Yeah. That's that's one of the ways that
it can be Yeah. It could be
understanding. Now, if you if you take a
look, do do me a favor cuz I I do have
to go, but I want to show you this last
thing on the same thing that you're at,
right? You're on Bible hub.
>> No problem. Yep.
>> Now, scroll down to Strong's Exaltus
concordance. It's right under.
>> Okay. What's a concordance? What's
What's a concordance?
>> It gives you the usage of the words and
the definitions.
>> Yeah. So, no, the concordance does not
give you definitions. It actually tells
you where.
>> Yes, it does.
>> One second. One one second. So, the
concordance does not actually give you
the literal definition and how it's used
in each and every single word.
>> It does.
>> One one moment. One moment. A
concordinance does not tell you how it's
used in every single verse, but it tells
you where it's used in every single
verse. And it tells you the general uh
the general uh
the general uh what do you call it?
The general the general definition.
>> Brother, can you can you just take a
look at it?
>> Logic. Logic. Logic. A concordinance
does not give you what's the verse
oiden. How the verse oiden is used. Yes,
it does within Mark. No, it does not
within Mark 13:32. Can you show me
within this?
>> I agree. I agree with you that it
doesn't give me the exact verse in which
uh it's being used. I I get you. But it
does give you the meaning. It does give
you the range of the word. And so I want
to show you Strong's exhaustive.
>> It gives you the I want you to get I
want you to see one of the definitions
of it. So it gives you general
definition. Just one second.
>> Does it give you general Does it give
you general definition?
>> Just one second. Can you scroll down to
see where it says it means to tell?
>> No problem. It seems
it says u
coordinates. No problem. A prim. Yes.
No. A a primary verb used only in
certain past tenses. The others being
borrowed from the equivalent opinomian
and haral. Probably to see literally
figuratively by implication in the
perfect tense only. To know be aware.
Behold, can plus not tell. Consider have
no have knowledge. Look, look on
perceive. Be sure tell, understand,
wish. Uh can Okay, no problem.
>> So it's used. So it can be used again.
Again, there's a land. There's a
concordance of you got your point.
>> No, I didn't. I just showed you this.
>> Go ahead.
>> So, I'm showing you that the word has a
range of meanings. One of the meanings
is to tell something, to make something
known, or to declare. So, with that
being said, and I showed you an example
of this in 1 Corinthians 2. So, with
Jesus, he doesn't declare the hour. It's
something that for the father to do.
When the father is ready to declare the
hour, he does it through the son. So, if
you want a explicit verse where Jesus
knows all things, you got John 16 30 and
31. And then also uh and John,
>> I want to ask you a quick question real
quick.
>> I I don't I don't have time. I I
literally have to go. I told you that.
>> It's just a quick question. It's just a
quick
ask the host.
>> He didn't have time.
>> Logic.
[laughter] Fine. Take care, guys. Ask a
quick question. The angels know the
hour. Do the angels know the hour? Do
the angels know the hour?
>> No, they don't. No, they don't.
>> Okay. Thank you very much. You just
baked yourself take know the hours you
don't.
>> That was embarrassing. I baked you. You
see how easy that is, guys? How easy
work that is? You see how excited he was
when he when I hopped on the stage. So
excited. Didn't know what to do with
himself. Wanted to argue Oiden. Didn't
even know that there's examples in the
Bible where the word oiden to know is
used in a declarative sense. He didn't
think that there was an example. He
hasn't watched enough. So, uh, next
time, brother. Next time. But hey, you
made it on the clip. Thank you for that.
Appreciate it.
>> [music]
[music]